So, to summarize what goes on in the new
way we are doing the RPC between the client
and the server. During the actual call, copies through
the kernel is completely eliminated. Right? It's completely eliminated because
all of the argument-result passing between the client and
the serving is happening through this A-stack which is
mapped into the outer space of the client and
the server. And so the actual overheads that are incurred
in making this RPC call is this client trap and
validation by the kernel that this call can be allowed
to go through. And switching the domains I told you
about this trick of doctoring the client thread to start
executing in the server procedure. That is really switching the
protection domain from the client address space into the server
address space so that you can start executing the procedure
that's visible only in this address space. So that is the
switching domain in the second overhead.
And finally, when the server procedure is
done executing, the return trap. That's the
third explicit cost. So three explicit costs
associated with the actual call. The first explicit is the client trap and, and
validating this BO. And the second explicit
cost is switching the protection domain from
the client to the server so that you can
start executing the server procedure. And the third explicit
cost is when we have this return track to
go back to the client address space. So those
are the explicit costs. But we know, having done
a lot of work on the operating system structure
early on, that there are implicit overheads that are
associated with switching protection domains. The implicit overhead is
the loss of locality due to the domain switching that's
happening. When we go from the client address space to
the server address space, we are touching, of course we
are touching some part of the address space, are going to
be in physical memory and therefore in the caches of
the processor. But, there's a lot of stuff that may
not be in the caches of the processor. So, there
is going to be a loss of locality due to the domain
switch that, that may happen. In the, in the sense that caches and the processor
may not have all the stuff that the server needs in order to do its execution.